cameras you love to take pictures well
this is an awesome way to do this is the
casio xf1 now it's not an SLR but it
does have some of the same features
let's just run through a few awesome
things so first of all you can do this
and it will capture up to 20 frames
which is pretty awesome it shoots 60
frames per second also it'll shoot high
def videos there's a little HDMI port
right here and if you want to student
standard-def video 1,200 frames per
second you could blow something up and
watch it in super slim I don't recommend
that you do that by the way but if you
were going to this will be the camera to
do it with also it has a slow motion
feature which let's say you're shooting
something that's moving a lot so you
point this you hold the button halfway
down and it'll play back in slow motion
the last second of time so you can
select the frame that you want and then
capture it this is a pretty sweet camera
not available commercially just yet but
when it is it will probably be just
under a thousand bucks so if you're
serious photographer this is seriously
your
you